fact or fiction lots of rumors you may
play Ariel can we make this that can we
make this rumor a reality no hey listen
I'm not the one in charge for that
zendaya sets the record straight on
rumors that she's set to play Ariel in
Disney's live-action The Little Mermaid
free wish I could be the actress may not
be part of that remake but she's gearing
up for a big role in small foot everyone
knows that the small foot isn't real so
many themes in this movie the first of
which is you're standing up in the face
of adversity standing in your truth when
was the last time you had to prove
something wrong or prove someone wrong
and I think you know it's important
message to have and I love that this
movie although it is obviously just a
kids movie I think they just have heart
and doesn't have messages and morals
values they're really great things
inside of it which i think is really
important today you made girls they were
crying when you came up over there I
mean that does have to make you feel
good like you're really affecting kids
out
I appreciate it of course it's always
love you know it's come from genuine
love and I appreciate that I love
the same so it's the best
[Applause]
[Music]